[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in Jim Jackson NBA on TNT
Clippers analyst and uh Fox college
basketball analyst what's on your mind
today
uh it's a little dreary here in Dallas
um
but what's on my mind is uh I mean a lot
you know college basketball starting
um my Steelers are not doing well which
um not too happy about but we did win
last week against the same how did you
become a Steeler fan growing up in Ohio
uh when I was younger honestly uh the
colors black and gold
so I mean this was in the 70s you know
you had the football sets the electronic
football games and all of that
Steeler fan all the way through Lynn
Schwann Terry Bradshaw Stallworth I
thought I was gonna be next to Lynn SWAT
but even though I mean I grew up closer
to Detroit
um but never was a lions fan never was a
Browns fan never was a Cavs fan I really
didn't watch Ohio State at all growing
up
do you ever meet crazy right did you
ever meet Terry Bradshaw yeah I met
Terry brochure and I met Lynn Swann and
I met Franco Harris
the best the best bro uh being in Dallas
what comes to mind what memory comes
back
you know it always this is where I
started my career this is where I kind
of grew up you know at 22 to 26
. and you know and whenever I come back
it's always a special moment you know
a lot of guys have a home so to speak
kind of if you played on a team or two I
I kind of don't but I do Dallas is kind
of where you know end of the day if you
say
where do you lay your hat what franchise
are you most familiar and I say it's the
Mavericks you know just a lot of people
a lot of friends have stayed here even
when I uh you know got traded from the
Mavs just because it was a city I
thought that was uh conducive to
Friendship business and everything else
so it's always great memories when I
come back to that but you guys had one
of those teams it's like you know Run
TMC they didn't win anything
but they had three Hall of Famers there
right but they played longer together
than us see people that the the
I think the conversation that people
tend to miss is this so it came in 90.
tell everybody so you had Jamal Mashburn
Jason kidding and Jason Kidd yeah right
but I I came first remember I had to
hold out my first my rookie year longest
holdout ever Jamal comes my second year
so we play 82 game together
then Jason Kidd comes my third year
Jamal's second his first but keep in
mind
the three of us never played a full 82
Game season together
why I got hurt my third year Jamal got
hurt the next year then we got traded
but within that I had
three different owners four different
coaches oh wow so it was never any
stability whatsoever so people think
that you know we were together three or
four years and we played all these games
no
honestly
never playing the 82 482 game schedule
and then going through the fluctuation
as you know Dad in sports and in
business if you're always changing the
front office philosophy if you're
changing the bench philosophy you you'll
never have any kind of continuity and
that was us in Balance so when people
talk about it like we were
you know destined to to do something yes
maybe but we never had a foot to stand
on in regards to any kind of stability
to see how good we could really be
we're talking to Jim Jackson he's uh
joining us from Dallas he'll be on the
call for the Clippers Mavericks uh last
night on the uh called the Clippers and
the rockets is Luca getting better and
if so how
it's you know when you're that good that
early you try to figure out ways to say
okay let me pinpoint
areas in his game that you can see the
biggest jump I think the biggest jump
for for Luca
was his efficiency in particular from
the three-point line and from the free
throw line because he can get to a spot
he can you know score but those two
errors he wasn't as eat fish he wasn't
shooting at 38 39 behind the three-point
line he wasn't at 85 from the free-throw
line why is that significant because
from a free throw perspective as you
know Dan in late game situations
you got to knock those in because you're
going to be the guy that's handling the
basketball so those areas he can still
improve him
and uh I mean he's young but he's so
mature as a player
um I think it's kind of unfair a little
bit because it's so much burden put on
him you know his users rages 38 so he
has to do everything and a lot of times
when you try to do everything
becoming less efficient even though
right now he's average he's leading the
league in scoring but it's so many more
ways he can improve and the way he does
that is by his team by making it easier
on him to be Luca instead of having to
do everything I know Jake here wants it
wants to ultimately do that yeah I don't
know if anybody has more of a workload
than he does night in and night no no
ah I mean and he takes it he doesn't
complain about it because as a young
player you always want you always feel
Invincible like well I can get it done
well I mean yes and as an older person
now looking back at it you love that
attitude but at the end of the day
you want to make it as easy as possible
for you to do your job and win games
because down the stretch even though
they got to the Western Conference
finals last year this is a different
team you want to be as fresh as you can
you don't want your body being beat up
um you know he's dedicated himself to
losing weight coming down and playing at
a reasonable weight but he does need
help to kind of another ball handler to
take the pressure off him and get him
some easy baskets you know
I know Vegas still likes the clippers
but without Kauai or I'm not sure you
know what his availability is going to
be yeah
um like what do you hear about Kauai
like short-term or bigger picture here
this way
you got to keep in mind
into the season
training cap was the first time Kawhi
went five on five first time
so and that was limited in some aspects
so I'm sure the medical staff was like
listen we're going to go through this
first couple months of the Season where
it's going to have probably some
swelling in the knee he's going to have
some pain and stiffness so we have to
monitor that because he hasn't gone a
whole year without really playing hard
full goal five on five
so these things were kind of expected
you know hurdles in the road pitfalls at
that the Clipper staff the medical staff
and Kauai would have to deal with early
on in order for him to be ready to play
mid-season second half of the season and
into the playoffs now what happens
though
is that when he misses games and Morris
misses games and Paul George misses
games and you don't have any continuity
in the lineup Ty Lewis trying to figure
out how to put all these pieces together
to make it make sense when you got guys
playing out of position which makes it
tough to win games so that's why you see
the fluctuation with the Clippers up and
down yeah because sometimes you don't
know who's going to be in the lineup and
what position more importantly they're
going to be in when they're in there
I'm going to make you Rob polinka
okay what are you gonna do
well okay if you make me Rob polinka
Michigan so that's why you want to do
that I know that's what you're doing
and he was on those five five teams too
we played so here's the thing
I think in the Lakers are more concerned
about the cap space for next year I
think they're 34 million
they don't want to
dig into that cap space at all so if you
do a deal with Miles Turner and better
Hill
buddy Hill has another deer on this deal
which is 19 million so that cuts into
that cap so you only got 15 million to
go after a free agent they don't want
that because if they really wanted that
they would do it now if I'm Rob polinka
too I'm asking myself if I do the Miles
Turner deal and Buddy Hill does that get
me to a championship
okay so if it doesn't is it worth
digging into my salary cap and then also
giving up two first-round picks 27 and
29. it doesn't make sense long term
short term it may appease the fan base
and say we win some games but it doesn't
get me to a championship caliber team no
and see that's a dilemma that people
don't understand is that what you
thinkers need to make a move it yeah
okay but does it get them ultimately
what they want to do which is a
championship and I think that's the
hesitation from the Lakers perspective
is those two things it doesn't really
get us to a championship and we want to
keep as much cap space that we have
possible for next year to go up their
big time create would you entertain the
idea of trading Anthony Davis
I would be open to it now it would
depend on who I can identify to get into
a position
to take over the reins of the Lakers
when LeBron leaves see because that was
the purpose of getting Anthony Davis
anyway right was to have a player in
place
able to assume the leadership role and
kind of be the guy when LeBron finally
be a free agency or he retired
so I think you ought to look at
everything because Anthony at this point
I think has proven that when he's
healthy is very good but he may he may
not be that number one guy that you
thought you would have had that you saw
coming from New Orleans so everything is
on the table I think from from the
Lakers perspective except for LeBron
being traded
well you can't trade them because he
signed his extension and you can train
him to August anyway
okay
all right so he he's not you know he
doesn't have any opt-outs in his deal in
this next couple years anyway so you can
trade him after August okay
right out you can't do anything yeah I
Anthony Davis was The Greek Freak before
The Greek Freak
he just stopped injury so but injury you
know you know one thing I looked at
Anthony
um I think what hurt Anthony Davis was
to me
did you he put a lot of weight up top
shoulders arms and say well why is that
well it puts a lot of weight on your
lower extremity and how many injuries
have he has he had more extremity why
because his body is built a certain way
he's a slim guy so he put the weight up
here which now he started to carrying
his hips knees and ankles now when you
come down on Dan you know you play ball
when you come down on somebody's foot
there's really nothing preventative you
can do with that but because you've been
hurt so many times
it just goes into something else when he
hurts an ankle well that affects his
knee that affects his hip that affects
his back it's everything yeah
I was wondering about I hate to see it
um I'll leave you with this
understanding the mind of a free throw
shooter
that you know we look at Ben Simmons and
say come on I mean it's a free throw you
know Carl Malone made himself better
Andre Drummond I mean a lot of guys Tim
Duncan yes I'm Duncan but can how do I
teach Ben Simmons to be a better free
throw shooter therefore in crunch time
he will want the ball and won't be
afraid to go to the basket well hold on
we leave it out Nick Anderson Nick
Anderson was 80 something percent free
throw shooter missed those critical free
throws in the in the uh against the
Bulls and never recover
yeah Baron Davis wasn't a great
free-throw shooter even though he was a
great shooter I think if Baron Davis
might have been in the 60s you know
here's the thing about Ben Simmons is an
outstanding case study of how fragile
the mentality is of a person that plays
Sports because
to me 75 80 of the game is mentioned
here's Ben Simmons a few years ago
wasn't afraid to get to the basket Mr
free throw so what he was Ultra
aggressive
when I watch him play we played him last
Saturday I forgot he was on the court
Dan
I forgot he was even out there it's
different than Ben Simmons no seriously
it's different if Ben Simmons had an
impact on the game defensively he was
pushing a rock he was getting all these
assistants okay he's not scoring but you
he has a presence and an impact I think
he's gotten to him so much mentally
in regards to what has happened up to
this point
that it's built a block in his mind he
doesn't even look at the rim and he's
the kind of guy then and I used to
always say this
in off season and practice he's shooting
the basketball with confidence he's in
there knocking down free throws in open
wreck he's doing it but when the lights
come on
and you don't see instant success where
that first shot goes in if it's an air
ball or a clean talk all of that work he
just put in rolled out the door
mentally he's not strong enough to fight
through that fat coupled with what he's
reading what he's hearing
outside the arena and the Miranda and
it's tough because he's such a talented
player how do you correct it that's a
psychological issue forget about
basketball
I think if something happened in his
life a roadblock came up it would be the
same kind of scenario in regards to him
blocking that out and being less
aggressive in whatever activity that was
I just feel that's his personality I'll
leave you with this we've been talking
about uh cookout songs your favorite
cookout song is what
oh Atomic Dog oh Parliament all right
little George George Clinton coach come
on I'm the 70s baby so that was all
playing in a little Shalamar out there I
mean I was that was back in the day bro
well wait Marvin what what were the uh
cookout songs that you had oh Frankie
Beverly and Maze Before I Let Go
always always That's a classic yeah uh
never too much Luther Vandross
too much never too much that's right
yeah
those are First Team all cookout songs
I never had a playlist for a cookout
song I was there for the cookout no no
no dance you see you got to come to I
I'd like to have a right now I do we do
a little bit differently you gotta have
if your music game out on point at the
cookout
try to do something
you might have the ass to leave bro okay
all right am I meeting Shorty's there is
that what's happening that's right
okay all right I got it
you know what I'm I'm all I'm all in I
think I need to go I need to experience
that a little bit okay you do man that's
one one of the highlights of your life
brother
a little Gin and Juice laid back I'm
good to go I'm good to go uh you gotta
have some cognac brother little Kanye I
can't do that
if you got to be accepted in the
Brotherhood brother round world
all right back to go too we give you the
purple bag you take it with you
uh safe travels all right brother that's
uh Jim Jackson NBA on TNT Clippers
analyst and fox college basketball
analyst as well